erinnern Sie sich noch daran wie viel
Spaß das Internet machte als es noch neu
war an memes Katzenvideos und Mashups
als es sich noch wie Hoffnung anfühlte
und Veränderung ich ging Ende des
letzten Jahrhunderts zum ersten Mal
online seitdem habe ich mich mit dem
Internet beschäftigt und Filme darüber
gedreht ich dachte immer das Internet in
die Hände der Menschen zu legen wäre ein
Rezept für Freiheit und Demokratie
das hat sich aber nicht bestätigt jetzt
sind die Internetfirmen riesig und
verhalten sich nicht wie unsere Freunde
zwielichtige Hecke haben unsere
Aufmerksamkeit erregt die Demokratie
untergraben und wir haben die
Katzenvideos gegen nazimims eingetauscht
das Internet wurde alt und irgendwie
langweilig
und ich auch
sie ist da ist ich habe das Gefühl gegen
die Bildschirme anzutreten und die
Bildschirme sind am gewinnen wie
Internet das Internet hat unsere ganze
Aufmerksamkeit gestohlen das ist Heim
türkisch eines Tages waren sie mit einer
intelligenten Zahnbürste auf der Sport
ihre Familie wird in der Cloud
aufgezeichnet und Ihr Kühlschrank
spricht mit Ihrem Telefon wie ist es
soweit gekommen
ich habe das Gefühl dass wir in einer
Zeit leben in der alles was nicht mit
dem Internet verbunden ist es bald sein
wird
ich glaube immer noch dass das Internet
einen höheren Zweck erfüllt aber es wird
jeden Tag schwieriger dem Glauben daran
zu bewahren mein Name ist Brad und ich
bin auf einer Mission das neue Internet
zu verstehen das Internet von allem
ces lasst uns Nerd werden
[Musik]
die Consumer Electronics Show ist
Amerikas größte gadget-messe hallo
was ist das das ist eine automatische
Katzentoilette ist die mit dem Internet
verbunden ja was ist das das ist ein
intelligentes sprinklersystem ist es mit
dem Internet verbunden ja natürlich ist
diese Windel mit dem Internet verbunden
hat oder ob sie gekackt hat
der größte Trend in diesem Jahr das
vernetzte zu Hause
Küchenarmatur sie lässt sich
berührungslos aktivieren sie kann
manuell aktiviert werden und jetzt auch
per Sprache die Verbraucher können also
Apple Google oder Amazon verwenden um
den Wasserhahn ein oder auszuschalten
und dann einfach ok Google
ich möchte Ihnen unseren Toilette zeigen
wir haben schon ein bisschen über
intelligente Toiletten gesprochen Amazon
alexa ist in dieses Produkt integriert
wenn Sie sich in diesem Raum aufhalten
können Sie Alexa nutzen um eine Stimmung
herzustellen Musik abzuspielen oder die
Lichter zu wechseln die gesamte
Funktionalität von Alexa ist also direkt
in die Toilette integriert
das ist eigentlich kein Ort an dem ich
Internet haben möchte warum habt ihr das
Internet in die Toilette eingebaut man
muss es nicht unbedingt auf der Toilette
benutzen es ist dafür gedacht dass man
es nutzt während man in diesem Raum ist
ah so bringt ihr also das Mikrofon oder
diesen Raum über die Toilette Alexa und
Google homes haben schon integrierte
Mikrofone ich biete nur eine nahtlose
Erfahrung und eine Art von Anwendung die
Sinn ergibt kann man das Mikrofon auch
ausschalten ja natürlich sie können das
Mikrofon jederzeit ausschalten genau wie
bei Amazon und Google okay verkauft
ich habe es verstanden ein Mikrofone
meiner Toilette ist das jüngste Beispiel
dafür dass Technologieunternehmen
versuchen sich unentbehrlich zu machen
Gegenstände in meinem Haus intelligent
machen
öffne den Mülleimer
auf der CES treten Google und Amazon mit
ihren intelligenten Assistenten
gegeneinander an und versuchen zu
beweisen wessen Assistent am
nützlichsten ist welcher in den meisten
Geräten eingesetzt werden kann und wer
den Krieg der intelligenten Assistenten
wirklich gewinnen wird diese Unternehmen
haben einen ganz neuen Blickwinkel auf
ihr Leben
da ist ein Computer in ihrem
Schlafzimmer ist ein Computer in Ihrem
Wohnzimmer da ist ein Computer der
zuhört da ist ein Computer mit dem man
redet da ist ein Computer mit dem man
befreundet ist warum Google oder Amazons
etwas bauen wollen ist total
offensichtlich das Geschäft von Google
ist nicht deine Suchmaschine das
Geschäft von Google ist es so viel über
sie zu wissen wie es nur geht es kommt
mir vor als wäre es erst gestern gewesen
als ich im Internet surfte und Google
mir nur helfen wollte einem Trend zu
folgen jetzt ist es ein mega Konzern der
mein Badezimmer zu Geld macht wer weiß
schon welche Folgen die Anbindung
unserer Häusern das Internet haben wird
aber sie findet trotzdem statt laut
Wikipedia werden bis zum Jahr 2020 also
bis heute 30 Milliarden Geräte dem
sogenannten Internet der Dinge beitreten
eine Pizza Drohne
das ist die unvermeidliche Folge dessen
dass die Computer immer kleiner werden
es begann mit industriecomputern
Computer waren unheimlich teuer am
it gab es einen den sich alle teilten
dann wurden die Computer billiger die
Leute fingen an sie an ihre Häuser zu
stellen
dann kamen Mobiltelefone und das hieß
dass die Menschen zum ersten Mal
vollständig online verfolgbar waren
und dann hat das Internet der Dinge alle
elektrischen Geräte in ihrem Haus online
gestellt
alles was mit Strom versorgt wird wird
irgendwann mit dem Internet verbunden
sein und das ist das Internet der Dinge
das Internet der Dinge ist wie ein nicht
enden wollender Goldrausch die
Möglichkeiten sind grenzenlos wenn man
alles auf der Erde vernetzen will das
ist eine Goldgrube für das Silicon
Valley
ist San Francisco so toll wie alle sagen
ja
die Unternehmen die unser Land und
unsere Welt im guten wir im schlechten
prägen sind hier entstanden uber Airbnb
Facebook Google die kommen nicht aus
Brooklyn sie kommen aus San Francisco
wenn du ein 22-Jähriger bist und dein
Glück in Amerika machen willst kommst Du
in Silicon Valley ich meine das Internet
der Dinge ist erfolgreich weil es das
Leben bequemer macht und die Menschen
sind bereit für ein bisschen
Bequemlichkeit auf alles Mögliche zu
verzichten
um einen Eindruck davon zu bekommen was
meine nordkollegen in den nächsten
Jahren auf dem Markt bringen werden bin
ich zu einem Investoren Pitch gegangen
wir sehen die interessantesten Dinge im
vernetzten Bereich als Dinge die durch
den Zugang zu Daten die Prozesse
verbessern ob das nun ein
gesundheitstechnologieprodukt ist dass
ihnen hilft allgemeine Muster in ihre
eigenen Gesundheit und der der anderen
zu verstehen oder ob es ein Produkt ist
das bei einem industriellen
Herstellungsprozess hilft alles wo es
eine Art Trojanisches Pferd in eine
größere Welt gibt finden wir wirklich
interessant
dass ich getroffen habe hat irgendetwas
zum ersten Mal mit dem Internet
verbunden nein es wollte Daten aus dem
Inneren eines menschlichen Körpers
sammeln
das ist keck es ist ein kleines Gerät
das vibriert während sie ihren
Beckenboden trainieren erfasst das keck
die Daten über ihre intime Gesundheit
und ihre Fruchtbarkeit diese Daten
werden dann in unsere Cloud übertragen
sie erhalten ein fruchtbarkeitsergebnis
können es aber auch exportieren und mit
einem Spezialisten verbinden es ist ein
sehr cooler Fitbit für ihre Vagina
das ist also eine gesunde Frau hier
sieht man wann sie ihren Eisprung hatte
und das ist das Zeitfenster in dem Sie
schwanger werden konnte ihre beste Zeit
war ungefähr hier dann haben wir eine
Frau die Probleme mit dem Hormonhaushalt
hat ihre empfängnisschancen sind
geringer und ihr fruchtbarkeitsfenster
viel kürzer es gibt eine große
Diskrepanz zwischen den realen Daten dem
was in ihnen vorgeht und der
Wissenschaft da gibt's eine Menge Unsinn
es wird also vielen Frauen wirklich
helfen die Hälfte meines Teams sind
Frauen Elektroingenieure jedes Mal wenn
wir etwas herstellen testen wir es
sofort wie ist es eine weibliche
Gründerin in so einer Energiewelt zu
sein okay das ist schrecklich warum
weil ich also okay der Markt ist riesig
aber männlichen Investoren ein Produkt
für Vaginas schmackhaft zu machen ist
eine große Herausforderung wie lange
hast du gebraucht um das alles zu
entwickeln von hier bis hier acht Monate
oh moment mal wurde ich eine Grenze
überschritten sollte der menschliche
Körper für das Internet tabu sein
Christina Startup überschreitet diese
Grenzen ebenso wie ein ständiger
stromtragbarer Dinge Implantaten und
anderer Geräte die dem Internet der
Dinge beitreten Unternehmen messen
unsere Herzfrequenz unsere Atmung
unseren Schlaf wir senden diese Daten an
unsere Telefone und in die Cloud sobald
sie in der Cloud sind werden Sie zu
einer Ressource die Unternehmen können
entscheiden wie Sie sie nutzen wollen
und einige davon verkaufen sie
datenmakler sind eine riesige Industrien
in Vereinigten Staaten das Sammeln all
diese Informationen und der verkauft
wurden traditionell für Marketing und
Werbung genutzt aber jetzt werden sie
mehr und mehr euch das Gesundheitswesens
und der Krankenversicherung eingesetzt
wo sie stufen dich ein auf der Grundlage
ihrer Algorithmen ihre Einschätzung ob
dein Lebensstil zu gesunden oder
ungesunden Gewohnheiten führt oder nicht
jetzt
wenn eine Frau Kleidung in Übergrößen
kauft wird vorausgesetzt dass sie eher
übergewichtig ist und er zu Depressionen
neigt also eher hohe Gesundheitskosten
verursacht das könnte dazu führen dass
man höhere Tarife zahlt
es gibt immer mehr Geräte die unsere
Gesundheitsdaten aufzeichnen können aber
die Technologie ist inzwischen so weit
fortgeschritten dass die Verbraucher
nicht mehr gesetzlich geschützt sind die
Daten können als auch viele Arten
verwendet werden von denen man sich
nicht einmal vorstellen kann dass sie
benutzt werden
das ist Eric er leidet an Schlafapnoe
und benutzt ein sepap-gerät um
nachzuschlafen ich schnarche sehr sehr
laut und halte meine Frau wach ab damit
das nicht passiert habe ich dieses
wirklich hässliche Gerät dass ich auf
mein Gesicht setze und das Luft
hineinbläht
es ist schrecklich aber man tut es aus
Liebe aber was Eric nicht wusste war
dass seine Versicherung sein Schnarchen
aufzeichnete und heimlich überwachte ob
er das Gerät richtig benutzt dann riefen
sie ihn an oh da steht sie haben sich
nicht an die Vorschriften gehalten und
ich sagte was soll das heißen ich habe
mich nicht an die Vorschriften gehalten
und sie sagte nun es sieht so aus als
hätten sie die Maske nur drei Stunden am
Dienstag und vier Stunden am Mittwoch
benutzt
und da hörte es für mich dann auf
armer Eric man hat seine Daten gegen ihn
verwendet seine private amerikanische
Krankenversicherung verweigerte ihm die
Kostenübernahme für eine neue m Aske
weil die Daten zeigten dass er das Gerät
nicht richtig benutzte
lassen Sie mich das klarstellen der
Grund warum sie mir die Maske nicht
geben ist weil ich mich nicht an die
Vorschriften gehalten habe und der Grund
warum ich mich nicht an die Vorschriften
halte ist dass sie mir nicht das geben
was sie mir geben müssten
das ist der Grund warum wir keck
gegründet haben keck ist das einzige zum
Patent angemeldete verbrauchergerät das
die vaginale Umgebung für die
Fruchtbarkeit erfasst das Gerät nimmt
also die fruchtbarkeitsdaten auf und sie
schauen auch wie man unsere Daten für
die Zukunft der Forschung nutzen kann
denn wie Sie sich vorstellen können
sammeln wir auch Daten von denen wir
noch nicht wissen wofür sie nützlich
sein könnten die kinderwunschärzte
werden sie hassen
der Gewinner unserer Sitzung ist keck
bitte kommen Sie nach vorne
[Applaus]
die Leute die diese Daten am meisten
wollen sind unsere Nutzer sie wollen
ihre Gesundheitsdaten kennen wir werden
also versuchen die Modelle auszuarbeiten
damit wir Geld damit verdienen können
aber ich würde versuchen den Verkauf an
Dritte möglichst zu vermeiden weil sonst
irgendein verrücktes Versicherungsmodell
für risikofrauen geschaffen wird und das
wollen wir nicht wirklich erzählen Sie
mehr darüber
wir wollen nicht dass jemandem einen
Nachteil entsteht nur weil wir seine
Daten haben die elektrische Zahnbürste
weiß wie oft man sich die Zähne putzt
sie weiß also wie hoch die
Wahrscheinlichkeit ist das mit den
Zähnen etwas nicht stimmt was ich dann
auf den Versicherungstarif auswirkt
und wenn Sie eine Frau haben die in der
Zukunft Fruchtbarkeitsprobleme haben
wird würden sie wollen dass Sie eine
höhere Versicherung hat
ich will das nicht ich persönlich möchte
das nicht
in der Zukunft zu leben ist seltsam und
verwirrend ich finde es gut was
Christina tut aber ich wünschte sie
hätte ein paar juristische Leitplanken
wir kennen die schlimmsten Szenarien im
Internet erst nachdem sie eingetreten
sind
und es scheint immer so zu sein dass
etwas das für den einen bequem ist für
einen anderen zum Albtraum wird
mein Name Istan und ich habe häusliche
Gewalt und insbesondere auch technischen
Missbrauch erlebt
mein Peiniger hat unser Smartphone gegen
mich eingesetzt und das als Mittel der
Kontrolle und Belästigung benutzt
alles konnte über diese App gesteuert
werden er musste also nicht mal in
meiner Nähe sein er konnte Tausende von
Kilometern entfernt sein mit diesem
technischen Missbrauch hatte das Haus
gegen mich benutzt indem er mir den
Schlaf Entzug und dieser Schlafanzug hat
die psychischen Qualen die ich
durchmachte noch verstärkt
ich schlief zum Beispiel nachts um 1 Uhr
tief und fest und plötzlich kam aus der
Stereoanlage diese schreckliche
gewalttätige Musik
man wird wachgerüttelt es ist
beängstigend denn es ist stockdunkel ich
machte natürlich das Licht an ging zum
iPad und versuchte die Anlage
auszuschalten und dann schaltete er
entweder das Licht an oder aus oder den
Fernseher an und aus den Ton ein und aus
das passierte nicht für ein paar Minuten
sondern vier fünf sechs Stunden lang
er nutzt es als Werkzeug um mich zu
belästigen um mich in meinem Haus zu
stocken
es ist schwer es ist schwer sogar mit
all der Trauma Arbeit die ich gemacht
habe ich werde immer wieder in diese
Nacht zurückversetzt ich werde
zurückversetzt in diesem Moment in denen
ich mich hoffnungslos fühlte ich fühlte
mich hoffnungslos
wir alle geben einen Teil unserer
Autonomie und menschlichen macht an
diese Geräte ab
immer ständig jeden Tag
die Berichte über häusliche Gewalt mit
Smart Home Technologie haben mir
klargemacht
wie schlimm es werden kann
die Dinge fühlen sich wirklich ziemlich
schlimm an und das geht nicht nur mir so
während ich diesen Film trete erreichte
unser Verhältnis zum Internet und seinen
mach an einen absoluten Tiefpunkt
sogar die Internet-Manager fühlten sich
schuldig
wir haben Werkzeuge geschaffen die das
soziale Gefüge der Gesellschaft ins
Wanken bringen
ich würde mich schämen wenn ich sie wäre
es war ein großer Fehler und es war mein
Fehler ich fühle mich unendlich schuldig
es tut mir leid es tut mir wirklich leid
dass das passiert ist
[Musik]
die Internet das Internet ein
wissenschaftlicher Durchbruch wird von
den Göttern bestraft intelligente Städte
werden mit Sensoren übersät sein die
alle durch das Internet der Dinge
miteinander verbunden sind
Ihre Matratze wird ihre Albträume
überwachen Ihr Kühlschrank wird piepsen
und nach mehr Käse verlangen Klick für
Klick Tab für Tab Daten der Computer
sagt ja oder er sagt nein was wird das
bedeuten rosa Olga Terminators die aus
der Zukunft zurückgeschickt wurden um
die menschliche Rasse auszulöschen was
ist hier los wir leben diesen
schmerzhaften Übergang der durch das
Internet verursacht wird und wenn es
nach der Geschichte geht werden die
Dinge nur noch merkwürdiger werden
jeremy riffkin hat andere Zeiten
massiver Veränderungen untersucht er
sieht ein Muster an diesen
apokalyptischen Zeiten des digitalen
Umbruchs
wir sprechen hier wirklich von einer
digitalen Revolution in der gesamten
Gesellschaft auf dem gesamten Planeten
wir müssen also die volle Tragweite
dieser Entwicklung verstehen und das
geht am besten wenn wir einen Schritt
zurücktreten und uns fragen wie diese
großen technologischen Umwälzungen in
der Geschichte zustande kommen
zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt tauchen
drei entscheidende Technologien in einer
Zivilisation auf und laufen zusammen
erstens neue Kommunikationstechnologien
um unser wirtschaftliches und soziales
Leben effizienter zu gestalten zweitens
neue Energiequellen die unser
wirtschaftliches und soziales Leben so
wie unsere Regierungsführung effizienter
gestalten und drittens neue Form der
Mobilität und Logistik um unser
wirtschaftliches und soziales Leben und
unsere regieren effizienter zu gestalten
an den seltenen Punkten in der
Geschichte an denen
kommunikationsrevolutionen mit neuen
Formen der Energie und der Mobilität und
Logistik zusammenkommen verändert dies
die Art und Weise wie eine Zivilisation
ihr kollektives Leben organisiert
laut riffkin wurde die erste
industrielle Revolution durch eine neue
Energiequelle ausgelöst Kohle die ein
neues Kommunikationsmedium Antrieb die
dampfbetriebene Presse und eine neue
logistische Infrastruktur die Eisenbahn
Lokomotiven Schienenverkehr habt ihr
habt Verkehr es entstanden die ersten
großen industriellen Ballungszentren und
unsere Geschäftsmodelle gingen zum
marktkapitalismus über
die zweite industrielle Revolution in
den USA ein weiteres zusammenlaufen von
Kommunikation Energie und Mobilität
veränderte alles das Telefon stellen Sie
sich vor zum ersten Mal in der
Geschichte im späten 19 Jahrhundert
nehmen die Menschen dieses kleine Gerät
in die Hand und ihre Stimme wird
praktisch mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit über
Tausende von Kilometern transportiert
später kamen dann Radio und Fernsehen
die Kommunikationstechnologien in den
USA mit einer neuen Energiequelle
zusammen den Ölquellen in Texas und dann
brachte Henry Ford den billigen
Verbrennungsmotor auf den Markt der von
Öl angetrieben wurde wir gingen von
nationalen Märkten zum Aufbau von
globalen Märkten über das hat unsere
Lebensweise verändert
die letzten beiden Revolutionen haben
uns eine vom Öl angetriebene Welt
hinterlassen das hat uns in die größte
Krise geführt die wir je erlebt haben
die zweite industrielle Revolution
verblasst gerade ich glaube wir können
es riechen und fühlen wir stehen jetzt
an der Schwelle zu einer dritten
industriellen Revolution
wir haben seit 30 Jahren das worldwide
web dreieinhalb Milliarden Menschen sind
in ihrer Kommunikation digital verbunden
dieses kommunikationsinternet das die
Menschheit verbindet läuft jetzt mit
einem Internet der erneuerbaren Energien
zusammen Millionen von Menschen
produzieren ihre eigene solar- und
Windenergie und was sie nicht
verbrauchen leiten sie in ein zunehmend
digitalisiertes Stromnetz zurück
ist das Kommunikation und Energie
bereits online sind und sobald autonome
Fahrzeuge über das Internet mit
intelligenten Straßen und städtischer
Infrastruktur verbunden sind wird die
dritte Revolution vollendet sein
kommunikations-internet digital Internet
der erneuerbaren Energien digital
Mobilität Internet digital um Energie zu
verwalten und die Wirtschaft und
Gesellschaft zu bewegen setzen Sie auf
eine Plattform und das ist das Internet
der Dinge
wir brauchen nicht auf selbstfahrende
Autos zu warten um zu sehen wie sich die
Art wie wir Dinge bewegen verändert hat
schon sein ist die Stadt die das
Internet gebaut hat jedes Mal wenn sie
etwas elektronisches bei Amazon
bestellen setzen Sie eine Kette von der
Ereignissen in Gang die hier durchkommen
dem hoher Chan baymarket 90% der
weltweiten Elektronik kommen über
schensen und das ist der Grund warum
dieses ehemalige Fischerdorf innerhalb
von 30 Jahren von 30 000 auf 12
Millionen Einwohner angewachsen ist es
ist das Zentrum chinesischer
Technologieunternehmen wie Tencent
Alibaba und Huawei das ist kein
aufgeblasenes Einkaufszentrum es ist
Teil der fortschrittlichsten Elektronik
Lieferkette der Welt
jede dieser Städte ist das Kundenzentrum
einer Fabrik am Rande von Shenzhen in
dem Moment in dem ich meine Bestellung
aufgebe verbindet mich das Internet mit
dieser Fabrik und wenn Sie ein neues
Gerät für das Internet der Dinge
herstellen wollen gibt es keinen
schnelleren Ort als Shenzhen auf diesem
Markt findet man jedes Teil das man
braucht um alles zu bauen was man sich
ausdenken kann deshalb hat sich
Christina der nicht enden wollenden
Parade von Startups angeschlossen die
nach Shenzen kommen und den Prototyp
Hack entwickelt
gekommen weil ich hier schnell schnell
Prototypen entwickeln kann wenn man z.B
in den Vereinigten Staaten einen
Prototyp herstellt dauert es ewig bis
man etwas bestellt ein Teil herstellt
oder einen Teil montiert hat aber hier
kann man alles an einem Tag machen
das hier ist alles neu diese
U-Bahn-Station z.B war vor einem Jahr
noch gar nicht da ja die sind hier super
schnell keine ist kurz tina ist auf dem
besten Weg zur führenden Nation der
dritten industriellen Revolution zu
werden
das ist im Westen nicht sehr bekannt
aber chinas Führung begann zu erkennen
dass CO2 ein großes Problem ist der
Vorsitzende des staatlichen Stromnetzes
hat eine massive milliardenschwere
Maßnahme angekündigt die jetzt im neuen
5-jahresplan umgesetzt wird um das
gesamte Versorgungsnetz zu
digitalisieren es zu installieren eigene
Energie zu erzeugen und das was nicht
benötigt wird wieder in das Netz
einzuspeisen Boom so geht das sie machen
gerade Millionen von Fahrzeugen
Millionen genau jetzt in den nächsten
Jahren sie sind schon im Produktion
es ist schwierig von Chinas
Geschwindigkeit nicht beeindruckt zu
sein aber die Auswirkungen auf die
Vernetzung einer ganzen Gesellschaft
gehen über intelligente Energienetze
hinaus und können nun ja noch
unheimlicher sein
chinesische Städte sammelt jetzt Daten
von Millionen von Überwachungskameras
vom öffentlichen Nahverkehr und von
Sensoren die in Straßenlampen und
Gebäuden eingebaut sind
Daten darüber wo sich Menschen aufhalten
und was Sie tun wenn Sie in Hang zu
leben sind sie Teil eines Experiment zur
Änderung des Verhaltens der Bürger das
als Social credit bekannt ist
[Musik]
wir können unsere Hand schon Bürger
transportkarte auf unseren Handys
benutzen um das Boot zu nehmen
heute habe ich meine Bürgerkarte benutzt
um meine Bootsfahrt zu bezahlen
Score soll die sozialistische Ideologie
und ihre Grundwerte fördern
es gibt viele Medaillen die sie
verdienen können drücken Sie einfach
hier es gibt mehrere Kategorien
Umweltfreundlichkeit Spenden für
wohltätige Zwecke Sport und Freizeit
CO2-arm heißt dass sie öffentliche
Verkehrsmittel benutzen wenn Sie zum
Beispiel den Wasserbus den Bus das
Lastenfahrrad benutzen oder zu Fuß gehen
können Sie Punkte sammeln und ihren
citizen Score verbessern mein aktueller
Punktestand ist 589 ich bin also auf
einem normalen mittleren Niveau
also wie düster ist das man bekommt
Punkte dafür dass man gut ist
kohlenstoffspart für wohltätige Zwecke
spendet und Sport treibt man kann seine
Karmapunkte gegen kostenlose Dinge
eintauschen aber die chinesische
Regierung hat mit Hilfe solcher Systeme
13 Millionen Bürger auf eine schwarze
Liste gesetzt die als unehrlich
eingestuft werden weil sie bei Rot über
die Straße gehen einen Kredit nicht
rechtzeitig zurückzahlen oder etwas
anderes tun das als unsozial gilt diesen
Nutzern kann das Fliegen die Anmeldung
bei einer Versicherung oder der Kauf
eines Hauses untersagt werden
verbunden wird das Ganze durch einen von
Alibaba entwickeltes Zahlungssystem das
Bargeld vollständig ersetzt hat sein
Algorithmus prüft Ihre Einkäufe um die
Vertrauenswürdigkeit zu bestimmen das
ist so als ob Amazon ihre Bank wäre
die Leute die für diese beiden Systeme
arbeiten wissen wahrscheinlich alles
über mich diese Systeme sind wie
detaillierte Portraits von ihnen
sie kennen ihre Lebensgewohnheiten ihre
Persönlichkeit und ihre Eigenschaften
ja vielleicht kennen Sie mich besser als
ich mich selbst kenne
wie stellen wir sicher dass die
Regierungen diese dritte industrielle
Revolution des Internets der Dinge nicht
missbrauchen um die Wahlen anderer
Regierungen zu hacken
das ist bereits im Gange wie stellen wir
sicher das Internetunternehmen sei es
Facebook oder Google oder Amazon oder
Alibaba dieses Internet nicht für
kommerzielle Zwecke monopolisieren den
Lebenszeit wird unserer persönlichen
Erfahrungen und unserer Daten zu wahren
machen Sie dann an andere verkaufen und
uns dann zu wahren machen und durch
algorithmensteuerungen unser Leben
lenken
das passiert bereits
Algorithmen spielen auch bei der
Verwaltung von Städten in Nordamerika
eine Rolle Vancouver war die erste Stadt
in Kanada die vorausschauende
Polizeiarbeit einsetzte
künstliche Intelligenz analysiert
datenüber vergangene Verbrechen sagt
voraus wo ein nächstes passieren könnte
und schickt Polizisten hin um es zu
verhindern der Hauptgrund dafür dass wir
uns für diesen Weg entschieden haben war
ein deutlicher Anstieg der
Eigentumsdelikte wie Sie sehen können
hatten wir hier allein im ersten Quartal
647 Wohnungseinbrüche
dann haben wir am 1 April mit der
vorausschauenden Polizeiarbeit begonnen
bis zum Ende des ersten Quartals Anfang
des zweiten Quartals ist die Zahl der
Einbrüche auf 438 zurückgegangen das ist
die niedrigste Zahl von Einbrüchen die
wir in den letzten 30 Jahren ermittelt
haben
wenn wir das ja aufrufen sehen wir die
aktive Prognose
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 Häuser ziemlich genau an
einem dieser sechs Standorte wird
wahrscheinlich
etwas Verdächtiges beobachtet
funktioniert das wirklich ja sie haben
die Zahlen gesehen wenn ein Polizist zu
einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt dorthin geht
besteht eine 30 bis 60 prozentige Chance
dass er das tatsächlich verhindern kann
man muss überall Polizisten haben an all
diesen Orten die alle zwei Stunden
rotieren
wir kommen gleich an der mcgealstreet an
wir sind also genau an der
vorhergesagten Stelle
sie glauben also dass hier mitten am Tag
eingebrochen wird ja sie würden sich
wundern zwischen zwei und vier gibt es
tatsächlich ziemlich viele Einbrüche
wir suchen nach jedem der aussieht als
würde er eine Wohnung auskundschaften
das ist algorithmische Polizeiarbeit das
ist das worüber wir hier reden das ist
das Aufkommen der algorithmischen
Polizeiarbeit die in alles eindringt was
wir tun die Polizei von Vancouver kann
bereits nach einem Jahr Ergebnisse
vorweisen in Los Angeles gibt es ein
solches System schon viel länger und es
hat einige unbeabsichtigte folgen
die 50 Blocks aus denen l.a geht row
bestehen sind eines der am stärksten
kontrollierten Gebiete der Vereinigten
Staaten in diesen 50 blockviertel leben
viele der 48.000 Obdachlosen der Stadt
hier ist auch die Stops zu Hause die
sich seit 2009 gegen die vorausschauende
Polizeiarbeit einsetzt
eine der Möglichkeiten über
datengesteuerte Polizeiarbeit zu
sprechen ist das bestimmte Gemeinden in
diesen Daten überrepräsentiert sind so
entsteht im Grunde eine
Rückkopplungsschleife in der immer
wieder die gleichen Einsätze in diesen
Gemeinden durchgeführt werden es geht
Roll liegt direkt neben einigen der
wertvollsten Immobilien von l.a ist
grenzt an den Arzt distract und das
Stadtzentrum über die gesamte Stadt Los
Angeles legt sich ein Algorithmus namens
Brad Paul Systeme wie Brad Power
analysieren kriminalitätsdaten um eine
Reihe von 150 Quadratmeter großen
Hotspots in der Stadt zu erstellen die
bestimmen wo Polizisten patroullieren
wann immer jemand verdächtige
Aktivitäten meldet sammelte Algorithmus
diese Daten jetzt stehen wir also genau
hier stimmts wir haben öffentliche
Unterlagen angefordert um zu sehen was
die Hotspots sind und die Brennpunkte
lagen an der Peripherie an den äußeren
Grenzen von skitro dann kommen die
gentrifizierer und ziehen dorthin sie
sehen dass jemand aus der skitroën die
Gegend kommt und rufen sofort die
Polizei ein Hilfe ruft dass eine
verdächtige Person dort unterwegs ist
die Idee ist also eine digitale Grenze
zu schaffen an der jemand aus der skitro
kommt und die Los Angeles Street
überquert wo ist hippe Bars und sowas
gibt man wird ihn dort an die Wand
drücken er wird belästigt und
eingeschüchtert und bekommt am Ende
einen Strafzettel
ich wohne seit 15,5 Jahren in der Skate
Roll bin also schon lange hier ich habe
gesehen wie sich alles entwickelt hat
wir sind in einer Situation in der
dieses unglaublich wertvolle Land von
gentrifizierungsentwicklern ins Visier
genommen wird was mich an dieser ganzen
Situation am meisten nervt ist die
entmenschlichen der Kriminalisierung der
Obdachlosen
glauben Sie es liegt auch an der
vorausschauenden Polizeiarbeit ja
absolut
Vancouver hat seine eigene Skate Bro
Downtown Eastside eines der ältesten und
widerstandsfähigsten Viertel der Stadt
die Bewohner haben einige der höchsten
Raten von Sucht und Geist des
Krankheiten in Kanada überlebt den
Bewohnern Algorithmen aufzudrängen wird
niemandem helfen
also was tun wir wir zwingen das System
wenn es dort eine Vorhersage erstellt
herauszugehen und die nächstbeste
Vorhersage zu nehmen denn wir wollen
nicht dass das passiert wir wollen keine
polizeilich-militärische Besetzung von
Gebieten in denen es offensichtlich
soziale und gesellschaftliche Probleme
gibt wie bringen sie Ethik in ein
solches System das kann man nicht und
genau das ist das Problem beim
maschinellen lernen es ist unmöglich ein
ethisches Unterprogramm dort einzubauen
es befasst sich mit den Parametern von
denen ein Mensch entschieden hat dass er
sie untersuchen soll und dann sagt man
ihm was das Ziel ist
mit KI lässt sich eine Menge anstellen
und ich denke eine Frage die man sich
auf menschlicher Ebene stellen sollte
ist sollten wir das tun
und ich bin mir nicht sicher ob diese
Frage oft gestellt wird und
wenn etwas das man tut einen gewissen
Gruselfaktor hat
dann sollten wir es nicht tun
unheimlich wäre es unheimlich in einer
Nachbarschaft zu leben die von einem
Unternehmen geschaffen wurde dass sich
mit der Überwachung von Menschen
beschäftigt
die Muttergesellschaft von Kugel heißt
Alphabet Alphabet besitzt ein
Unternehmen namens
im Jahr 2017 heißt der Eric Schmidt von
Alphabeth nach Kanada und schlug vor das
Sideboard Labs in Toronto eine
Nachbarschaft auf dem Internet aufbaut
[Musik]
wäre es nicht schön wenn man technische
Dinge die wir kennen auf Städte anwenden
könnte all diese Dinge die wir tun
könnten wenn uns jemand einfach eine
Stadt geben und uns die Verantwortung
übertragen würde das war kein Scherz sie
haben eine Stadt vorgeschlagen die das
Internet einbindet aber wenn man
versucht so googeln wie das aussehen
wird findet man nur Bilder die wie
Science Fiction Cover aus den 70ern
aussehen
das einzige was klar ist ist dass das
Internet überall sein wird und dass die
Google Schwesterfirma in vollem PR Modus
ist
wir werden die Grünflächen erhöhen und
die Dichte
ist eine neue Art von Gemeinschaft hier
am Wasser in Toronto es geht darum wie
neue Technologien die Städte für die
Menschen besser machen können
sie sehen hier gerade eine Straße die
für zwei Fahrspuren ausgelegt ist das
ist wahrscheinlich zu viel für eine
Straße dieser Breite man könnte sich
also vorstellen dass man sie am
Wochenende wie einen Platz nutzen möchte
sie wird also weiß mit roten
Absperrungen an der Seite oder
vielleicht wird sie morgen zu einer
Fahrrad Autobahn man hat also
Fahrradspuren in drei Richtungen und
einen Zebrastreifen damit die Leute
darüber können
das Konzept das sich
herauskristallisiert ist eine
anpassungsfähige Stadt die auf
intelligente Weise auf Signale reagieren
kann die über Wetter Verkehr und
Menschen gesammelt werden
ich finde es wirklich spannend dass die
Stadt in Echtzeit reagieren kann und das
ist etwas das durch Daten möglich wird
würden Sie Informationen darüber
preisgeben wo sie arbeiten damit die
Stadt in gewisser Weise auf sie
reagieren kann
ich möchte nicht dass Big Brother mir
die ganze Zeit über die Schulter schaut
das würde mir nicht gefallen
es ist also ein schmaler Grat wie viele
Daten nicht weitergeben möchte oder die
Art und Weise
wie die Daten weitergegeben werden alle
Daten die wir sammeln dienen nur dem
Zweck den Ort für die Menschen besser zu
machen und wir haben uns von Anfang an
Gedanken darüber gemacht wie wir die
Privatsphäre jedes einzelnen während
dieses Prozesses schützen können wie
würden Sie die Daten erheben würde ich
gerne wissen nun das hängt von der Art
der Dinge ab über die wir hier sprechen
der Zauberer will dass du auf die Hände
guckst aber was passiert da drüben die
Hände sind im Moment Gebäude oder Geräte
oder autonome Fahrzeuge oder was auch
immer was ich abspielt ohne dass jemand
darauf achtet ist dass eine
Infrastruktur für alles gebaut wird für
die physischen Räume für das Zuhause für
alles mögliche ich meine damit dass im
Grunde genommen die ganze Welt in die
Lage versetzt wird die Geschäftsmodelle
der großen Technologieunternehmen zu
unterstützen die Städte werden immer
mehr Daten über uns sammeln und daran
ist nicht unbedingt etwas auszusetzen
verbessern können unsere Städte besser
machen im 19 Jahrhundert stoppte ein
Wissenschaftler namens John snow einen
choleraausbruch indem er jedes Mal wenn
jemand an der Krankheit starb meinen
Datenpunkt auf eine Karte setzte die
Kombination der Daten mit der Karte
zeigte das verunreinigte Wasserpumpen
die Übeltäter waren beim Kampf um Daten
in unseren Städten geht es nicht nur um
den Datenschutz es geht um
Privatisierung genauso wie
Technologieunternehmen an den Weg
gefunden haben unsere Badezimmer zu Geld
zu machen eröffnet die Anbindung unserer
Städte an das Internet noch mehr
Möglichkeiten für Unternehmen stellen
Sie sich vor das nächste U-Bahn will
mehr für die Bordsteine Zahlen an denen
die meisten Menschen stehen
oder ein neues Startup will sie zur
nächsten freien Parkbank Lotsen
natürlich im Tausch gegen Werbung und
ihre Standortdaten
dieser Prozess war immer von der Frage
umrahmt wie man eine Testumgebung in den
portlands schafft die Frage sollte
lauten wollen wir ein Testfeld in den
portlands wollen die Leute eine
Testumgebung in einer Gegend haben in
der Menschen leben werden kann sich
jemand hier im Raum daran erinnern
dieses Konzept unterschrieben zu haben
schauen Sie sich den Zustand des
Internets an es hat eine massive
Zentralisierung sowohl der Infrastruktur
als auch der Unternehmen gegeben die im
Grunde das Rückgrat des Internets bilden
wenn man also diese Dinge nimmt und sie
in der physischen Welt repliziert ist
das für mich der falsche Weg
privatisieren wir kommunale
infrastrukturdienste unsere öffentlichen
Güter niemand gibt mir eine Antwort es
heißt immer nur wir arbeiten daran wir
arbeiten daran ich denke bevor wir
darüber reden was sie auf dem Gelände
bauen wollen sollten diese Fragen am
ersten Tag beantwortet werden und nicht
erst am Ende
wissen sie Technologie und Informatik
nichts von diesen Dingen ist von Natur
aus kapitalistisch die Regierungen
können sich selbst mit diesen Werkzeugen
ausstatten und Sie können einen
öffentlichen Dienst haben der weiß wie
man diese Werkzeuge benutzt und diese
Kapazitäten der Regierung aufbauen
trotz aller Widerstände schien der Plan
der Sideboard Labs unausweichlich gibt
es nur zwei Möglichkeiten für die Stadt
der Zukunft eine Überwachungsstaat oder
ein unternehmerisches Experiment
[Musik]
Barcelona geht einen Mittelweg die Stadt
ist führend bei der Gestaltung
intelligenter Städte lehnt die Kontrolle
von Daten durch Unternehmen ab und macht
den Start gegenüber den Bürgern
rechenschaftspflichtig
für uns sind Daten wie eine weitere
öffentliche Infrastruktur die
Wasserstrom Straßen die Luft die wir
atmen und deshalb müssen diese Daten ein
gemeinsames Gut für unsere Bürger sein
wir wollen weg vom
überwachungskapitalismus hin zu einer
digitalen Wirtschaft in der Daten ein
Allgemeingut sind und wir kollektive
Aktionen durchführen können bei denen
die Menschen wissen was mit ihren Daten
passiert und wie sie den Nutzen der
digitalen Gesellschaft maximieren können
in Barcelona dienen die Daten den
Menschen nehmen Sie die Smart
citizeninitiative das ist ein einfacher
Sensor der lokal 3D gedruckt und frei
verteilt wird die Sensoren wurden in der
ganzen Stadt installiert um Daten über
CO2-Emissionen Umweltverschmutzung und
Lärm zu sammeln die bürgerüben dann
Druck auf den Stadtrat aus damit der
Ruhezone einrichtet
Smart citizen ist ein Projekt von FabLab
Barcelona die Maschinen und die Menschen
hier verwandeln Informationen in Dinge
anstatt einfach nur eine Abhandlung
darüber zu schreiben wie wir uns die
intelligente Stadt vorstellen haben wir
gesagt komm machen wir ein Projekt
daraus machen wir einen Experiment bauen
wir etwas wir entwickeln Werkzeuge für
die Datenerfassung und die Weitergabe
von Daten und dann sehen wir wie wir die
Leute dazu bringen sich daran zu
beteiligen
wenn man in einem FabLab fast alles
herstellen kann dann kann man auch die
Dinge herstellen die in einem FabLab
fast alles herstellen oder also kann man
Maschinen herstellen die Maschinen
herstellen die Maschinen herstellen
anstatt Smartphones aus China zu
verschiffen kann man sie in jeder Stadt
vor Ort herstellen man kann etwas in
Barcelona entwerfen und das könnte
überall auf der Welt hergestellt werden
man muss also keine Materialien
transportieren um Informationen zu
transportieren
im Jahr 2014 gab Barcelona ein kühles
Versprechen ab alles was die Stadt
braucht sollte innerhalb von 40 Jahren
vor Ort produziert werden Kleidung Autos
Telefone alles
ich möchte das Barcelona die führende
Stadt in der neuen industriellen
Revolution wird
im Rahmen des fabcity-projekts das sich
zum Ziel gesetzt hat Städte dazu zu
bringen bis 2054 alles was sie
verbrauchen vor Ort zu produzieren
versuchen wir diese fablabs als eine Art
Rückgrat auszurichten um den Übergang
zur lokalen Produktion in den Städten
einzuleiten aber gleichzeitig als
verteiltes und offenes Netzwerk weltweit
zu betreiben
zurzeit haben sich 28 Städte der
Herausforderung gestellt die wir 2014 in
Barcelona gestartet haben die Mission
ist ganz klar wir wollen dafür sorgen
dass wir auf diesem Planeten leben
können ohne unsere Zukunft zu gefährden
jeder kann dem FabLab Network online
beitreten sie glauben dass sie durch die
Produktion vor Ort den Abfall und die
kohlenstoffkosten für den Transport von
Materialien reduzieren können es ist
eine dringende Aufgabe anastasia hat
sich angeschlossen um neue Materialien
zu erfinden die auf nachhaltige Weise
hergestellt werden kann
es gibt verschiedene Materialien und
wenn man eines davon machen will muss
man nur dem Rezept folgen das sind die
aus lebensmittelabfellen
und die hier aus Orangenschalen kann das
Plastik ersetzen ja was soll das 24
Jahren ändern
alle reden von fast fashion warum machen
wir also nichts super fast fashion das
ist sogar noch schneller weil die Leute
Konsumenten sein wollen also sagen wir
okay wenn du konsumieren willst dann
gibt es vielleicht einen Automaten der
dir ein T-Shirt aus Biokunststoff
verkauft du kannst deine T-Shirts aus
Bio-Kunststoff tragen wie Aschenputtel
und dann kannst du sie einfach wegwerfen
ohne dich deswegen schuldig zu fühlen
und dann machen sie es wenigstens so
dass es etwas ist das den Planeten nicht
schadet
um die Vision der Fab City zu
verwirklichen nach der die Städte in 40
Jahren autark sein sollen müssen wir
herausfinden wie wir Lebensmittel
herstellen und eine neue Beziehung zur
Natur haben können das greenfablab wurde
im Central Park von Barcelona
eingerichtet und den Anfang zu machen
von der Herstellung von fast allem bis
zum Anbau von fast allem Autarkie bei
Materialien in der Produktion bei der
Lebensmittelherstellung bei Energie und
Wasser
es geht darum zu verstehen was wir
brauchen und was wir produzieren können
die fablabs sind wunderbare Orte um
etwas zu schaffen und die Macht der
Produktion in den Händen zu halten
als ich hierher kam sah ich das fair
bleib Barcelona und dachte das ist der
richtige Ort für mich denn hier kann ich
mich mit meinen eigenen Projekten
beschäftigen und zwar auf einem ziemlich
fortgeschrittenen Niveau
aufbauend auf Smart citizen haben
Jonathan und seine Freunde Open Source
Bienenstöcke entwickelt aus dem
summenden Geräuschen im Inneren des
Bienenstocks übersetzt eine Software
diese Daten so dass die Imker die
Gesundheit der Bienen überwachen können
man kann alle Dateien herunterladen und
sie auf eine cmc-maschine laden um sie
selbst zu bauen
ein bisschen wie ein ikea-bausatz seine
Schrauben kein Kleber du hast es einfach
zusammen
die Bienen verlieren ihren Lebensraum
und sie werden gemanagt stark gemanagt
und so ist es irgendwie interessant sie
einfach tun zu lassen was sie tun wollen
sie zu beobachten nicht zu versuchen
ihre Produktion zu maximieren sondern
mit ihnen zu arbeiten
auf eine etwas langsamere Art als ich
mich auf den Weg machte um
herauszufinden wie sich das Internet
entwickelt hätte ich mir nicht
vorstellen können dass ich im
dreckhocker und einen Bienenstock
betrachtete es ist verrückt aber es ist
wahrscheinlich weniger verrückt als das
Internet der Dinge für jemanden der vor
30 Jahren gelebt hat erscheinen würde
wir stehen erst am Anfang von etwas
wenn sich jemand diesen wunderschönen
Ort in den Bergen mitten in Barcelona
ansieht würde er sagen dass es so kleine
meine ganze Stadt mit Strom zu versorgen
ist das ein Hinweis darauf wie es in
Zukunft aussehen wird
der schwierigste Teil des Wandels von
dem ich glaube dass wir ein Teil davon
sind ist nicht sich die nächsten 50
Jahre vorzustellen oder die nächsten 40
Jahre im Fall unserer Stadt sondern es
geht darum was in den nächsten zwei
Jahren passiert wie fangen wir an wie
sieht der Übergang aus wir haben Öl
Nutzer einem sehr geringen Teil
verwendet also können wir uns durchaus
eine Zukunft ohne Öl vorstellen das
Problem ist jetzt damit anzufangen ich
glaube das ist die größte
Herausforderung wir müssen den Übergang
schaffen ich glaube es reicht nicht aus
nur Visionen von einer Zukunft zu
entwickeln
große Ankündigungen ja ich denke das
reicht nicht das sind alles Ausreden um
eine Zeitplan zu haben aber jetzt geht
es darum ihn auch zu verwirklichen
manchmal höre ich mir selbst zu und
denke das ist so naiv schön dass du da
aber gleichzeitig frage ich mich welche
Alternative ich habe um es zu schaffen
in den Anfängen des Internets gab es
keine Geschäftsmodelle keine Nutzer die
man erfassen konnte keine Daten die man
auswerten konnte
der Zweck des Internets stand direkt auf
dem ersten Logo die Worte lasst uns
teilen was wir wissen
was ich in Barcelona gesehen habe war
der erste Schritt hin zu Menschen die
diese Aufforderung zum Wissensaustausch
nutzen um die größten Probleme zu lösen
die vor uns liegen
das un-panel zum Klimawandel sagt dass
wir jetzt 11 Jahre Zeit haben um die
gesamte Welt zu verändern von jetzt an
befinden wir uns im krisenmodus jeder
der glaubt dies sei das Zeitalter des
Fortschritts das ist Geschichte das ist
das Zeitalter der Widerstandsfähigkeit
können wir das in ein paar Jahren
schaffen wir haben die gesamte erste
industrielle Revolution in 30 Jahren
geschafft wir können es in 20 Jahren
schaffen aber wir müssen jetzt aufwachen
und dabei wird uns diese digitale
Revolution helfen
seine Christina ihrer Mission treu
bleibt hat sie die macht das Leben von
Millionen von Frauen zum Besseren zu
verändern und wir versprechen mit Ihren
Daten richtig umzugehen könnte
tatsächlich profitabler sein als sie zu
verkaufen
mit dem Einstieg in die Massenproduktion
in China hat sie etwas gewonnen dass sie
vorher nicht hatte
ist mein Tag ich werde nicht also ich
habe die keck App hier das ist meine
Grafik ich glaube Christie wird Erfolg
haben weil die Welt zu 51% aus Frauen
besteht und so wenig in unsere
Gesundheit investiert wird
denn wissen ist Macht oder ich habe
keine Zeit um zu warten und Gott weiß
wann schwanger zu werden ich bin schon
39 ich habe keine Zeit zu verlieren
christina hat eine Crowdfunding-Kampagne
gestartet die in weniger als zwei Tagen
ausverkauft war sie hatte genug
Bestellungen um Amazon zu umgehen und
direkt an die Frauen zu verkaufen die
ihr Produkt brauchen die Frauen die auf
unserer Warteliste reserviert haben das
sind jetzt etwa 4.000 innerhalb von ein
paar Wochen das ist ziemlich verrückt
die andere Alternative die sie im Moment
auf dem Markt haben sieht so aus
viel Glück
technologische Technologie ist weder gut
noch schlecht noch neutral vor allem das
Internet wir können es nutzen um Dinge
auf neue Weise zu machen oder wir können
Dinge machen die uns benutzen
auf der anderen Seite ist das ein großer
Sprung nach vorn für die Menschheit weil
wir uns jetzt vorstellen können dass die
gesamte Menschheit überall auf der Erde
virtuell und physisch miteinander in
Verbindung steht zu jedem Zeitpunkt
wir bringen die menschliche Familie
zusammen in unserer Generation wird man
auf diesen Moment als einen enormen
Wendepunkt für die Menschheit
zurückblicken jetzt wo wir alle
miteinander verbunden sind beginnt die
eigentliche Geschichte
ich glaube wir sind die Kinder des
Internets wissen Sie was ich meine das
andere Internet ist nicht verschwunden
es ist da aber wir schauen woanders hin
drück einfach auf Aufnahme starten
sich das Internet meiner Jugend zu
wünschen ist eine Art schlechte
Erziehung denn dieses Internet wird
denen hier nichts nützen das ist so als
würde man sich darüber beschweren wie
cool der Telegraf war
diese ganze Sorge um das Internet ist
wirklich altbacken denn für sie gehört
es einfach zum Leben dazu
wo hast du diese Bilder her
ja was ich jemandem sagen würde der sagt
das Internet wird die Welt ruinieren ich
würde sagen du magst recht haben aber
ich hoffe du hast nicht recht das hoffe
ich auch Kind vielleicht wird mein
Internet alt und langweilig aber dein
Internet kann alles sein
[Musik]
everything everything everything
everyday
[Musik]